so in hello everyone my name is Martine
again a I work in a startup based in
Edinburgh home all Z what we do is
fashion and we work with fashion we work
in retail and I'm going to leave you
through how we're building a
recommendation engine to recommend
products meaningful to our customers so
a little bit about the product and the
context and why we're doing this in the
first place Molesey is a fashion mobile
app application where you can swipe
include so it's known as the tinder
profession because what you can do is
you can given given an image you can
decide that you like it when you swipe
right or you don't like it and you swipe
left we have shows accessories and all
sorts of clothing from thoroughly from
brands so we collect of the main source
of data these swipes which are complex
objects a what you can then do for the
ones the products you save you can also
buy them directly from the app itself
hence i also have all the orders data
for our customers which which then have
the price attached to it so I match the
person spent a then there's all sorts of
bits and pieces you can do you can
search for items through a full text
search you can save your feed suppose
you're interested in blue jeans from
certain brand in but important bit here
is that you can set certain brands to be
your favorite by tapping on this star
here so in this image you see this user
has selected two favorite brands this is
going to inform my recommender we'll see
how in so the first challenge which is
actually the main one is to come up with
the right data if you want to build a
recommendation algorithm this is the
image of one product which is a print
t-shirt from this brand here in with
this price in this color so what we have
against the product of metadata which we
scrape from retailers websites is
the brand the type which is identified
by the this icon here a the gender
whether it's female or male and the
color which is again comes from this
desire I can hear the price which is
sold now we have a series of images
coming again from the retailer website
and all full text really which
encompasses several bits I'm going to
describe so what we do is we have a
massive job of a scraping data out of
other way other websites and formatted
to our standards by doing some
classifications specifically on the type
and on the color because we have our own
tags hence we need we had to train some
classifiers for this job and then we
insert it into our databases so print
t-shirt in this case is the name of the
product that this is part of the text
other big part of the text we have is
the so-called description which again
comes from the website and in several
cases not open many it's not meaningful
at all like you can read here this was
describing this t-shirt here the name is
pretty informative but the description
is not so you have something related to
the length the fit the the fabric and
then there's bits and pieces about how
you're supposed to wash this item and
what is the model height or something so
if you want to understand what the
product is based solely on this
description you see that we have a
problem here this is not enough a hence
what we do is we have a natural language
processing simple job to extract what we
call keywords out of the description so
the words which actually describe
something against a product which are
meaningful in this case keywords for
these will be print t-shirt which is a
big remit another token so like two
words and short sleeve which is
somewhere around here here we go all the
rest is rubbish
a so we did this furnishes the basis of
our recommendation engine because we're
only dealing at the moment we met a data
and with text we haven't touched on the
images yet that will be the next step so
the goal is to provide everyone with
meaningful Taylor to you recommendations
so that you can open the app and say oh
these are the new products among those
these are the ones we think you might
like why because mostly because people
expect this feature these days so how
does the algorithm work and with some
preliminary analysis first of all we
start from the brand's we have and what
we do is we manually tag their Styles
across 14 features of styles which we
tagged with the racing with an integer
ranging from 0 which means not at all
the 3 which means it is very high in
this tile feeders are like active which
is that's the brand's L activewear up to
which sustained basic if you have pretty
much stuff for everyday life bohemian if
while we dresses and skirts classic is
stuff which is monochromatic and
straight in shape a dark if the if the
brand how much the brand favors dark
shade designer those brands which are
which come from a name of one edgy if
it's the little a little bit weird a
flamboyant if it's very flashy graphic
if it and compassed some cultural items
like writings or images usually t-shirt
occasion is if them the brand sells a
clothing for events sporty it's usually
only the way around where these sort of
things try and if it's fashionable
usually appeals to the younger
demographics urban STD life and vintage
is if it's a little old-fashioned how we
came up with this set of tags which are
just 14 this has been through
brainstorming exercise across the
company where we were just creating
words for describing the old possible
styles we can think we can we call that
towed off and then extracting the ones
which are emerging in terms of frequency
so again we manually map the the styles
for each brand because there is no way
you can extract this information out of
the description of a brand anywhere and
this is the correlation matrix of the of
the brands across of those sorry of
these features across the whole brand
data set so you see that some things
like urban and trendy are predict
related to each other which is not
surprising while maybe occasion and
graphic are not again make sense and
there's all sorts of bits and pieces
this one's graphic and urban are also
relatively correlated and we use this
information to build the first feature
in our recognition algorithm another
sanity check is to cluster the brand's
to see whether we have some patterns
emerging so brands which are actually
similar to each other in what we do is a
k-means of course by whereby you can
derive the optimal number of clusters as
to be has to be hate it with this number
so you see that it pretty much makes
sense cluster 0 will be brands which are
designer then we have class or two which
are brands mostly located around
activewear hear me we have edgy brands
mmm very very specific things we have
probably something like the sporty /
trendy things here guys whoo-hoo
misguided this stuff are trendy these
ones are a bit designer a bit ed Jim so
you from a human point of view it makes
sense it looks like it's not perfect
it's a k-means how do you use this all
this stuff a so the first step would be
going from the side profile of a brand
to the style profile of a user in such a
way that I can say for each of the users
we have how active how basic how trendy
they are and this will furnish our first
feature how do we do this so B let us
call you the user and be the brand and I
the index on the style feature so from 0
to 13 across the 14 styles let us grab
them the favorite brands of user you
call ed holiday and the set of non
favorite brands the ones he didn't upon
what we compute is the ratio of saves
the the person has on each of these
brands be so how many items did actually
swipe right for that brand across the
total is wiped for the brand and then we
have the manually mapped a style for
feature I on brumby orders if the person
has bought something we factor design as
a swipe and this is meant to boost
somehow the counts for durations and
then we pass through them from them the
style profile of brand B to the style
profile of the person who was wiped in
the app by doing cooking everything
together in a big weighted average which
I couldn't ride here because it was it
was too long but I can give you the
tails in the idea then for doing this is
to coming up to come up with the first
feature to feed the model with so I can
show you these are the ratios I have on
several brands the green bars are the
number of saves the the red bars are the
number of hidden sigh have on this
branch so you can see that this is this
is me this is my user I wipe quite a lot
on SP Antonio figure and I like them
quite
out a agent m levi's i also like white
them quite a lot bear in mind that one
of the challenges behind all this all
this data preprocessing is that it's
very easy that people swipe left while
finding something that you like is much
more difficult so people are picky and
they make sense so it's not the case
that you have classes like saved and
height which are balanced they're not at
all hence you need to to build a model
which makes sense with very unbalanced
we are very balanced situation but given
that thing and given the weighted
average we use it this will be my side
profile so this is me it looks like i am
pretty high in classic i'm pretty high
in occasional also basic and I don't
like edgy and flamboyant or designer
things so a good recommender will have
to capture this information and not show
intuitively not show me stuff which is
around those areas of style so the first
feature we have out of the style profile
which is this distribution here for user
is the similarity to a brand so giving
yourself in your in your 14 dimensional
space of style and giving given the
brand which leaves again in the same 14
dimensional space we just compute a
cosine similarity which takes care of
giving you a rating of how much you are
matching that brand the idea behind
these is that we want to match users
with brands even if the user knows
nothing about the brand you may not
never have heard about this brand and we
won't steal to recommend him meaningful
things we don't want a rich gets richer
process whereby okay you like Asian am
quite a lot you swipe a lot on a tiny we
keep recommending you H&M because in
fashion is look it this is not a good
idea if I buy or like skinny jeans from
H&M and I bought two I maybe don't want
to be recommended a turd because I might
not buy it simply because I don't need
it
we want to be robust in what we
recommend you in terms of whole the
projects we have which are many a now
this is the first feature we feed the
algorithm with a the second feature
would be the ratio you have on a type so
types are t-shirts skirt dresses boots
heels we have I think around 20 types
what we do is the same thing so we
calculate the ratio of saves you have on
each of these types and we do the same
with the colors we have thanked probably
15 colors which we again classify
through a classifier for the product in
we calculate the ratio you have on black
which you have them brown and white so
we can understand what you prefer white
/ gray or something and then I've shown
you before we have the keywords for each
product so we also know how much you
save for each keyword keywords are
attached to the type so within jeans you
will have one keyword rich my be skinny
jeans it's a big run and we might
recognize that you like skinny jeans
forty-six percent of the time say so we
use the ratio of saves as our main
ingredient third step is actually to
build the training sets for users so we
cram all these together given all the
swipes that the user has created we
insert we use the brand's molarity again
as a cosine similarity type saves ratio
the color sex ratio and we compute an
average of the ratios of the keywords
for that product I'm at the same time
this will be the training set for user
given the swipes he has created at the
same time because we want to recommend
you normal things so things which came
into the app the previous week what we
do is compute the same features we will
be the ones to predict upon for the new
products and this is done on a per-user
basis so as you can imagine it's
relatively expensive
if we use a classifier who is a random
forest we train it on the training sets
of swipes per user and we apply to the
new products of the week so that it
spits out a binary classification
whereby we are able to recognize that
you love this product or you won't like
it a now how do we validate this why
little bit tricky so on the good users
whatever that means and what that means
is that they swipe quite a lot but they
also swipe well in the sense that they
give us enough data on each brand enough
data on each type enough data on each
keyword and color there are these users
but there's also a bunch of users who
either swipe just on one brand or they
only search for jeans today and they
open up the app three months later and
they search for something else so that
we don't have good data to start with
but on good users the measure score done
through cross validation is productively
high but given a given a look at the
confusion matrix we see that it is
fairly easy to recognize that you don't
like something so he'd then recognized
predict as a hidden it is less easy to
recognize that's like something this is
because of the imbalance of the several
biases we have in the data so it is food
photos to come up with a better maybe a
better way to compute the style profile
maybe different features we didn't think
of and in general it is so much easier
to predict that you don't like something
then that you like something on top of
that with those users which are bad so
don't we don't have enough data in the
first place it is really full photo to
understand what to do maybe we might
want to instead of doing recommendations
per user we might want to do
collaborative filtering approach and
grab things like we are similar so i
recommend you stuff which comes from
someone else's feet in now if you
consider the staff profile of users and
you um you define did the count sorry
the ratios as a probability distribution
which you can compute is the entropy of
this distribution and you will see that
there is a nice envelope which looks
like almost ocean but there's also some
pics this is the peak of the so-called
trendy users to one which a favorite
those brands which are in the trendy
trendy space and this is um
unfortunately it's an inner and bias you
can't do much about usually fashion
works in trends and there are several
brands which are popular and trendy they
only appeal to a certain young age
demographics and they produce lots of
products while the edgy ones the phone
boy and the designer ones are more
Neesha so it is more difficult to get
enough data about them this is in inner
end to how fashion works a this would be
me across a test we did in the office so
we produce the actual feeds for
ourselves a with the weekly product a
who's classification per user is a one
so it means it's um it's a yes you like
it this will be myself so what we did
was a very sort of a high level
validation of our what are these things
make sense in the first place and to see
how many we could recognize in the feed
us oh I would have actually save this so
you were right so it looks like it's it
is relatively good but again there are
the limitations i have exposed a the
main problem is how to scale this up
which is why which is what we're working
on it on on at the moment because we
have good amount of you a good number of
users
and we want to be giving this
recommendation to everyone again very
tailored to you how do we do this if so
we need to do a good compromise between
time complexity and storage and what we
came up with was we built a training set
for the large number of users and we add
weekly to it with the news wipes you
have produced during the last week we
cleverly try to manage the computation
on the fly and the storage so like we
don't recompute the ratios you have on
the brand and the type on the color
every time because this will be very
expensive but we keep track by relying
on storage of the count so they would
just really compute the division so that
we add to the counts every week and then
we use spice Park we use park so it all
comes down to transforming code which
was running in a notebook in nice by
it's a nice IQ learn into sequel queries
pretty much in and then we use amazon
web services we rely on text files
stored in ash tree so that we can read
them easy-peasy with spark a this is
just a nice example a nice couple of
examples of how the code actually looks
like if you're familiar with spice Park
it as a sequel sequel context which
enables you to to to use the sequel like
api's so we call the context a we write
a load of a UDF for example in this case
we want to compute the numerator in the
style profile for the user in so we
write lambda functions and then
everything becomes nice joints and
selects so the code is very long a
afterwards after we have built the
training set we also have another pie
spark job which does the actual
recommendation so for each of the users
we grab the training sets we have both
previously
we compute the features per user on the
new set of products for the week and
then we cram it all in a pipeline for
the model so index the status which is
saver height so that's the class we
assemble it by selecting these four
features i have described and we call
them we hold the actual model and we put
everything together in a pipeline we fit
the model and we actually run the
prediction aim so that would be me
thanks for listening to a head of
schedule clarify so we've got 12 minutes
for questions we have already one
question at the back remember to repeat
the question in the microphone right
yeah yeah so I was expecting this
weigh-in well oh sorry the question was
about him why did I chose a random
forest so why did I choose a
classification procedure let's say
that's because as you have seen we don't
have the features beforehand so like we
have to do not only a feature extraction
which is transforming a text into
numerical features but also with a goal
of either building so i don't have the
features of the product i have to build
them so i have to go through this long
process of coming up with a style
profile and then brand similarity and
then computing the ratios so to me it
looked like the sort of traditional
approach rule don't work in this case
hence i transform it all into a
classification job of deciding given the
features of the new products and given
the ones you have for all your swipes it
just becomes a job of performing a
binary classification specifically why
the random forest because our out of
several analysis that was the algorithm
which was performing better given the
computation time allowed we could afford
another question at the fact that i had
in mind so please go ahead
okay so first question is about what's
this weighted average how is it computed
in the first place which I didn't show
here so this is just this is just an
average which takes into account the
ratio you have on a brand the swype so
you multiply these this number by this
number and you use a coefficient to make
sure that if a user favorites lots of
brands it means that is not very picking
means that it's very loose so you give
them a score which is on just a matter
of how many brands he favorite out of
demo and how many it didn't so it's just
a weighted average I didn't show because
it was it was looking very ugly really
but it's just a weighted average of
these three ingredients there's no
random weights or something is just
really pray it's really computation the
second one is about why we plan on doing
about the trendy users which might be a
bit of a challenge because it might be
the case that there if there's many of
them and you see there's many actions as
the peak is pretty high whether we are
thinking of doing something bespoke for
them training a random forest or
whatever other classifiers with fine
tuning a specific on those this is
something we haven't done yet but we
plan on doing and I don't know yet what
what exactly to do and what cost
function to maybe describe I have the
feeling the intuitive feeling that for
how the model works at this very moment
it would be the case that these users
might get sort of very very similar
recommendations and if we it's a matter
of understanding from the business point
of view whether we want to discriminate
between them all we are happy we giving
them sort of a very similar feed because
at the end of the line they are similar
and they might respond to it in quite
satisfactorily so it's a matter of
understanding whether it's worth to
differentiate so we might want to do a
clustering of the users as well and take
different approaches based on how peaked
the distribution of a user is across
styles or how spread it is yes we
haven't we haven't applied anything yet
in this case but yeah would be good to
investigate okay so the question is
whether we in the training sets we can
see they're all the history of swipes
and that the answer is yes because we
already don't might not have enough data
about it what about you swiping on a
brand on a type on a color so at this
very stage we consider all the ones
because the more the idea the intuitive
idea is the more you swiped better the
ratios become second question is whether
we factor in the seasonality this is
done through the fact that we don't
recommend products extra considering the
full stack of products we have we only
get the weekly ones the ones which came
in to the last week which are of the
order of the thousands so there's plenty
already to choose from and so we are
sure that we are only recommending stuff
which is really new otherwise it doesn't
make sense because it might be the case
that this product is not produced any
more if it was from last year or so
how do you how do you mean embedding the
way in users in the space of the
clusters with which clusters yeah okay
okay okay okay thanks so L sorry yeah
that was the suggestion more integration
was about to make a better use of
clustering products and users together
and it was about new sort of method of
paper from google actually how's it go
again wasabi okay so I'm gonna have a
look thank you
yeah so the question is whether I plan
on using magic factorization which is
one of those things you do when you're
building a recommendation usually
traditionally the reason why I didn't do
this is that the matrix you have tones
of users and you have even met many more
products you have many more products
than users and the mattress will be not
only very big but also very very sparse
so it will become really a computational
challenge I'm not sure it would really
you would be the right approach but if
we want to do a collaborative filtering
might be the case if we come up with a
with a better matrix so that we pre
process the users by clustering them so
that we can actually have a smaller
matrix I'll bite in sparse that might
make sense for a collaborative filtering
approach which is not the case of out
the algorithm is working at this very
moment I don't know what's the limit is
but you can imagine that products are in
the orders of the millions users depend
on depend on how many you consider but
you have a million of products and you
have users who have only sweat on 200 of
them and you have those who have in the
best case they have swiped some hundred
thousand because they've been using the
app for ever since but there's no such
thing as a user who has wiped Donna
honest in a consistent part of the
product base so
yet that's what I was saying we plan on
doing especially for the so-called bad
users to one which don't swipe them yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I know I know but
because we want to be exactly very very
tailored to you because there's this
problem that infection you know I don't
want to give you right yeah okay sorry
so the question was about instead of
training around them for every single
user which seems like a very expensive
procedure any DS why don't you come up
with them with a random for a strain for
every user at the same time by cramming
together all the features in one line
yep yeah definitely it's all work we
plan on doing thank you I think we
should yes keep give a warm hand to
Martina for great tour